هذا هو جمال دبي فقط
لأنها مدينة لدينا فيها جميع
جنسيات العالم ، كما تعلمون ،
كل شخص لديه غضبه الخاص ، عالمه الخاص ،
فهو على دراية بموقف
ما ، لذا إذا أحضرت الجميع
في نفس المكان ، فسترى  مثل
الألعاب النارية للإبداع ،
سأعيشها ، أنا دانييل بدلاً من ذلك معًا ، نحن
مهندسون معماريون ومصورون ،
نهجنا هو اللعب باحترام
وهندسة داخل مشهد حضري
والسياق الجانبي نسافر حول العالم
لاستكشاف ورؤية جوانب المباني
حتى نتمكن من  أخبر قصصًا للصورة ،
نحن رحلة للقاء
المبدعين الآخرين المتشابهين في التفكير والملهمين في
دبي ، نعم ، سنلتقي مع
شقرا منشئ المحتوى العفوي ، نلتقي
مع ريمي لمشاركة نهج نيك
ونبدأ من خلال النظر بعين الطائر
من دبي ، أنا أستخدم الجهاز منذ ثلاث
سنوات الآن ، لذا يعرفني الكثير من الناس
هنا كفرنسي في الطريقة التي أقوم بها بالمحتوى الخاص بي
الذي أفعله من الصور ومقاطع الفيديو
، وأعتقد أن أي شيء  قبعة
يمكنني أخذها من الكاميرا الخاصة بي من هاتفي ،
أحب أن أحاول العثور على
محتوى مبتكر كل يوم وإلى الفريد الذي
أعتقد أنه في المدن الرائعة
لإنشاء محتوى لديك الكثير من
الأماكن المختلفة لأنه كان جيدًا
والناس بالفعل  جربته ولكنك
تريد محاولة العثور على زاوية جديدة أحاول
الحصول على إبداعك الخاص ، فأنا لا أخطط
كثيرًا لتسجيل كل لقطة بأسلوب
ألعبها بالضوء مع الظلال
بالحركة لدي هذه الفكرة وأستمر
في  أنا أقوم بتصويره ، أقوم بتعديل سريع
على جهاز الكمبيوتر الخاص بي وأقوم
بنشره ، فهذا الأسلوب المندفع للتصوير الفوتوغرافي لراما
مثير جدًا بالنسبة لنا بالطريقة التي
يعمل بها عقله بسرعة لإكمال سرد
لصورته ، فهي رائعة في
دبي ، إنها سهلة حقًا بالنسبة لك  تعرف خطوة
إلى الوراء قليلاً ، يمكنك أن تأخذ كل شيء في
كيف أن التصميم الجميل
وواجهاتهم يتمتعون بروح أكثر إبداعًا
في التصميم بمجرد أن تصل
إلى القمة ، يمكنك أن ترى كيف تم
الاعتناء بكل شيء ويمكنك أن ترى  كل
د  يرى البريد الإلكتروني كيف تم إنجاز كل شيء
ليكون جميلًا في الهندسة ، وأعتقد أنني
عامل مجتهد حقًا لقد عملت ربما
ستة أيام في الأسبوع.
سريع جدًا وأعتقد أن هذا هو
جماله ، يمكن للجميع أن يكونوا
منشئ محتوى اليوم ، ما هو صانع المحتوى ،
إنه ليس أنا فقط ، يمكن أن يكون
أنت ، يمكن أن يكون أي شخص لا أعرف حتى
إذا كنت سأصبح مصورًا  في غضون
عامين وأنا أحب أن
هذا الإبداع هو الذي ألهمنا
حتى لخلق صورتنا الخاصة أثناء وجودنا في
دبي وسنزيل المغامرات السيئة التي
نفكر فيها معنا لمشروع مستقبلي
أعيش الحلم
حقًا للعيون
[موسيقى]